in the aftermath of the dollar flu vital
Supply is being delivered across the U.S
were severely hampered
but truckies of the old America would
band together for the greater good of
the rising settlements across the
country
however with these factions of hero
freities there would also be a growing
Fleet that have realized the power of
this situation and have decided instead
to use it to their advantage
thank you
foreign
[Music]
over 80 percent of all communities in
the US rely exclusively on trucks to
deliver all of their fuel clothing
medicine and consumer goods
the Romans were some of the men and
women who hauled these goods from state
to state in their large Freight vehicles
they transported materials livestock
Machinery liquids General Freight and
sometimes hazardous substances
the Alice could be incredibly long and
in conditions that were often stressful
including Paul weather and heavy traffic
repeatedly they were required to travel
long distances which meant spending many
a night far away from home
highly skilled in handling their large
Vehicles they also possess some basic
knowledge of the mechanics of their
trucks and how to maintain them
in the novel written by Thomas Parrott
the division recruited the Romans were
the ones identified as running the
northern routes in addition they are now
also in control of the Cumberland Gap
tunnel that carries the U.S Route 25e
under the Cumberland Gap National
Historical Park
the importance of this particular tunnel
is because it represents one of the only
safe ways for large vehicles to pass
through the mountains between Kentucky
Tennessee and Virginia after the green
poison outbreak
this passage passes through the
Cumberland mountains and consists of two
separate balls which carry four lanes of
traffic
until recently this tunnel was firmly in
the hands of the non-hostile faction
called freitis
but now the Romans are the ones in
charge
a rogue Army of truckers using the might
of Commerce to seize control
some people decided it was time to
become the worst possible version of
themselves when they realized the world
was ending and the rumors are some of
these people
essentially they are Smugglers and
they're aspiring to be the kings of the
areas under their control
they bring much needed supplies to
people but as soon as these same people
become reliant on them they've gotten by
the throat and they hold on tight
enslavements under any other name
as long as the ones they Supply to
follow their explicit instructions to a
tea they will provide them with just
enough to keep them going
and if they don't if they dare to rebel
against them they'll take what they want
anyhow anyway and destroyed everything
else
their attire consists of leather
bandanas worn Denim and Boots similar in
resemblance to a classic motorcycle gang
the way in which the Romans Act is also
quite interesting is they tend to carry
themselves in a similar manner to the
true Sons
a lot of them have an arrogant and
exaggerated Swagger to their walk and
they love to gloat when they are
victorious and they know they have won
they've turned the trucks into weapons
and have applied rough paneling to
better protect their vehicles
these cargo carriers have been modified
into improvised Fighting Machines with
guns mounted on them and some are even
equipped with machine gun nests and
small artillery pieces
they also carry a variety of small arms
mostly SMGs and assault rifles along
with the occasional M40 rifle
in the story of recruited division
agents Myra Brenda and Leo would learn
of the Romans while heading Southwest
from Maryland on their mission of
locating the reason behind supplies not
being delivered to communities down the
Eastern side of the country
up to 6 million people who managed to
survive the green poison are now facing
an impending famine
approaching a group of well-armed truck
drivers hauling themselves freighties
they would find out that similar to the
freighties the Romans are former
truckies
the Romans and the freities have had a
hostile relationship since the country
first began to fall apart but it was
more of a cold war where the freighties
were in the Southern Roots and the
rumors ran the North
like the freighties they too would run
supplies out to communities but their
methods were a little different
the freighties were really only
experiencing small skirmishes with them
to begin with and they were certainly
able to Halt their own
but eventually the roamers started
pushing South
at first it's just small probing raids
they'd be in and out before the
freighties could react but they knew
they were coming
eventually the rumors would come and
force it was now obvious that they knew
everything about how the freighties were
formed and how they moved and the
freighties had been on the back foot
ever since
now the Romans have set up a barricade
at the Cumberland Gap tunnel
if they were to help the division agents
were supplying food to the east coast
they would need help removing this Roma
threat
the agents agreed to help the phrase but
admitted that something didn't seem
quite right with what they were saying
about the Romans it was like they were
getting Intel from somewhere within the
freighty's camp or perhaps something
much worse
division agents have a key piece of kit
that helps them be one step ahead Isaac
this AI assistant provides access to
satellites radar and so much more
it was beginning to sound like there was
a rogue agent within the Roman ranks
it would take a couple of days for the
freighties to get their attack party
ready but that was okay as this would
give the agents time to scope the place
out and prepare for the upcoming battle
on the day of the planned attack
all seemed calm the rumors seem to be
going about the usual duties at the
blockade
there were more than 20 trucks with many
armed men
more than enough to stop the freighties
on any normal day
but this wasn't any normal day
today they had a new weapon
three division agents along with their
state of the art is HD gear
the agents were able to use their tick
and surprise to their advantage quickly
taking out a number of trucks via sticky
bombs before the Romans had any idea
what was happening next several turrets
that have been deployed the night before
popped into action spraying the
barricade with AI driven machine gun
fire and user identified sniper rounds
at this point the Freddy's had also
arrived and were pushing forward with
trucks as well as a number of offensive
weapons ranging from Small Arms fire to
heavy machine gun platforms to mortars
being fired from the rear
it wasn't long before the entirety of
the valley was swallowed by the fury of
a pitched battle
the Roma's lack of training and
discipline could be seen across the
battlefield as burning figures bailed
out of their ravish trucks
men and women of the barricade trying to
establish where this attack was coming
from were unleashing fire in all
directions some of them around the
perimeter would be cut down by friendly
fire in the chaos
Roma and Freshies alike died in droves
as the two fleets clashed
the agents took a second to scan the
battlefield and observe how everything
was playing out
the freakies were ahead having taken
advantage of the early wins the agents
had given them
but suddenly they noticed something was
off
the turrets had stopped firing
but they weren't out of ammo
they were reassessing their targets
their attention seemed to be now focused
on the freighties
someone had hijacked and turned them
against them
the agents were able to neutralize the
turrets as well as a drone that had
opened fire on them during the conflict
but before they were able to question
what was happening a familiar voice
echoed around them
an agent recently turned Rogue made her
presence known
this agent was Rowan she was once a part
of this cell a traitor
coming from the badly damaged drone
Rowan antagonized them mocking them for
their predictability and stating that
although the Romans had lost this battle
that the agents had done more in the
short period of time and she was able to
do over the last several months
to show the rumors that the division
were the Real Enemy
Rowan was an agent that went too far she
weaponized a sample of the green poison
this drew the attention of arankina's
Rogue agents Rowan then used the
weaponized sample against an encampment
of true Sons by poisoning their water
supply
Rowan was incorrectly informed by one of
the agents that her family was killed by
the true Sons when in reality they were
imprisoned on Roosevelt Island and were
killed in the crossfire when the
division engaged against the growing
hostile faction of outcasts
however Rowan's actions against the true
Sons admit the approval of the outcasts
and with their leader having now been
eliminated by the division they were in
need of someone new to follow to give
them a purpose
after the success of the battle at
Cumberland Gap the freighties were happy
to help in supplying the Eastern
communities
while appreciative after the discovery
of Rowan made them realize that the true
threat was what Rowan had planned for
the division itself this incursion for
her was more about gaining the trust of
the Romans
now she had the Romas the outcasts and a
plan to attack one of the division's
cause
Decor contains a large amount of
classified information weapon designs
satellite feeds the names and location
of division cells and all sorts of other
important Intel
predicting these was of utmost
importance for the division
now I'm going to cut off the story here
I've already delved far deeper into the
division recruited story than I'd
planned to summing up three division
agents managed to get to the core
located in Kansas but what met them
there was a battle that had been
reaching on since long before they'd
arrived involved with the Romas the
outcasts and the rogue agent Rowan
the three agents would of course join
the fight against odds far tilted out of
their favor
but this was for reasons far beyond
themselves
if this facility was to fall it wouldn't
just affect them it would
be with hundreds of shd Agents across
the US
perhaps later on I'll dive deeper into
the events around the division recruited
but for now I think this gives a pretty
good understanding of who the rumors are
and what they've been doing
regarding the Black Tusk and how they've
been using the Romans as of season 10 I
can't really be sure at this point but I
believe the recruited story to have been
playing out alongside the events of
season 10 but even if they weren't I
still see them as a faction that is
still active within the Midwest
[Music]
I can actually feel Thomas Parrott
cringing at my attempts to describe this
faction and how their partner stories
played out I really don't think I've
done it justice in comparison to his
work in the book so if I have made you
intrigued with this video at all and
you'd like to know more I'd really
suggest picking up the division
recruited I'll place a link to this in
the description
and while I'm on that there is a reason
I didn't cover these in the recent video
where I spoke about the season 10 Target
lucky
I had left it open and purposely didn't
delve into who the rumors were when they
were mentioned
for much the same reason that I don't
cover leaks
but I managed to get hold of Thomas and
Lauren from Ubisoft and I was given Neil
clear so here we are people put a lot of
work into these stories and out of
respect for them I don't want to be the
reason they get spoiled early on
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this video
an extremist malice extremely remedia
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]